the fool says in his heart there is no
God we read that statement twice in the
Psalms Psalm 53 verse 1 and Psalm 14
verse 1 double confirmation
so according to the Bible who says in
his heart there is no God
the fool the the dummy the
imbecile
actually the Hebrew word for fool here
refers to someone who's a fool in a
moral sense rather than an intellectual
sense it's not someone with a low IQ
it's someone who stubbornly rejects
wisdom and correction
now when the psalmist declares the fool
says in his heart there is no God
is he talking about atheists
is he calling atheists fools
there should be a glaring problem with
that interpretation namely that atheism
wasn't really a thing in Israel a
thousand years before Christ pretty much
everyone King David ever met would have
been either a monotheist one God or a
polytheist multiple gods atheism no God
wasn't much of an option so it seems a
bit odd to think that King David was
making fun of atheists and yet I've seen
quite a few Christians quote Psalm 53 1
in response to atheists so lots of
Christians seem to be convinced that
this claim is about people who don't
believe in God
and that completely utterly totally
misses the point read the relevant
Psalms carefully and you'll realize that
this claim the fool says in his heart
there is no God isn't about atheists
it's about you
it's about me it's about all of us
and these Psalms are teaching a very
important lesson that everyone needs to
learn Psalm 53 and Psalm 14 are very
similar so we'll read one of them psalm
53. and then we'll read another Psalm
that clarifies what these passages are
ultimately saying Psalm 53
the fool says in his heart there is no
God they are corrupt and their ways are
vile there is no one who does good God
looks down from heaven on all mankind to
see if there are any who understand any
who seek God everyone has turned away
all have become corrupt there is no one
who does good not even one
now if you're a Christian but you've
never read this Psalm this should still
sound familiar because the Apostle Paul
quotes some of this in Romans 3 where
he's showing his readers that we're all
sinners
so Paul thinks this applies to all of us
not just atheists there is no one who
does good not even one
but then David the psalmist here turns
his attention toward oppressors in
particular people who are oppressing the
Israelites
do all these evil doers know nothing
they devour my people as though eating
bread they never call on God
but there they are overwhelmed with
Dread where there was nothing to dread
so God eventually punishes the
oppressors
God scattered the bones of those who
attacked you you put them to shame for
God despised them oh that salvation for
Israel would come out of Zion when God
restores his people let Jacob rejoice
and Israel be glad
did you catch anything that was
specifically about atheists
Psalm 53 Begins by saying the fool says
in his heart there is no God but then it
says that we're all Sinners and it goes
on to address specific sinners
what's going on here
if you read Psalm 53 carefully enough
you can figure out what David is really
saying but it's easier to spot the
meaning in Psalm 10. let's read Psalm 10
for clarification
why O Lord do you stand far away why do
you hide yourself in times of trouble
in arrogance the wicked hotly pursue the
poor let them be caught in the schemes
that they have devised for the wicked
boasts of the desires of his soul and
the one greedy for gain curses and
renounces the Lord
so because God stands far away meaning
that he doesn't immediately intervene
the Wicked Man devises schemes and
curses and renounces the Lord
in the pride of his face the wicked does
not seek him all his thoughts are there
is no God
all his thoughts are there is no God
sound familiar
is this talking about atheists let's
keep reading his ways Prosper at all
times so he keeps getting away with it
because God hasn't judged him yet
your judgments are on high out of his
sight as for all his foes he Puffs at
them he says in his heart I shall not be
moved throughout all generations I shall
not meet adversity
look at what he says in his heart he
says in effect since I've been getting
away with what I've been doing for a
while I'm obviously going to get away
with it forever
his mouth is filled with cursing and
deceit and oppression under his tongue
are mischief and iniquity he sits in
ambush in The Villages in hiding places
he murders the innocent his eyes
stealthily watch for the helpless he
lurks in Ambush like a lion in his
Thicket he lurks that he may seize the
poor he seizes the poor when he draws
him into his net
the helpless are crushed sink down and
fall by his might he says in his heart
God has forgotten he has hidden his face
he will never see it
now that's interesting here the Wicked
Man doesn't say there is no God instead
he says God has forgotten God has hidden
his face God will never see it
still think this is about atheists
arise O Lord O God lift up your hand
forget not The Afflicted why does the
wicked renounce God and say in his heart
you will not call to account
notice here the wicked man isn't
claiming God doesn't exist he's claiming
God won't hold me accountable for my
actions
but you do see for you note mischief and
vexation that you may take it into your
hands to you the helpless commits
himself you have been the helper of the
fatherless break the arm of the wicked
and evildoer call his wickedness to
account till you find none the Lord is
king forever and ever the Nations perish
from his Land O Lord you hear the desire
of The Afflicted you will strengthen
their heart you will incline your ear to
do justice to the fatherless and the
oppressed so that man who is of the
earth May strike Terror no more
Psalm 53 Psalm 10 and Psalm 14 all refer
to people who say inwardly there is no
God and if you ignore the rest of what
these Psalms claim it's easy to think
that the psalmist is talking about
atheists a closer examination however
shows that these Psalms are about people
who sin people who take advantage of
others people who oppress others and who
think that they're going to get away
with it
when someone steals an old lady's purse
he only steals her purse because he
thinks he's going to get away with it
if he knows he's going to get caught
he's not going to steal her purse
when someone commits fraud or adultery
or murder he's only doing it because he
thinks he can get away with it if he
didn't think he could get away with it
he wouldn't do it
so according to the Psalms when we sin
we've somehow convinced ourselves at
least temporarily at least briefly at
least for a moment
that we're going to get away with it
but there's a God who sees and knows
everything which means that no matter
what we think we're not going to get
away with it forever
if you believe in God you know you're
not going to get away with it forever
but you sin anyway as if you think
you're going to get away with it
this means that even if you believe in
God when you sin you're acting like you
don't believe in God you're acting like
you won't be judged for your actions
so when Christians Jews Muslims Hindus
Buddhists and yes even atheists lie
cheat steal whatever we're saying in our
hearts there is no God or that God
doesn't see or that God doesn't care we
are exhibiting an internal attitude that
we can escape Justice
regardless of what we believe when we're
thinking clearly we have an ability to
suppress the idea that we're going to be
judged for what we do
that's what Psalm 53 and Psalm 10 and
Psalm 14 are talking about
to be clear some people do this far more
than others Psalms focus on people who
are doing some really really awful
things
but again Paul applies this to all of us
if you sell your car to someone and you
completely rip him off and trick him
into paying three times what the car is
worth you've said in your heart there is
no God even if you're a Christian
now we could read these Psalms
and look around at the world and
conclude that atheism is The Logical
next step in our efforts to avoid the
consequences of our actions we could
view atheism as an attempt to
intellectualize the inward Rebellion
that the Psalms draw attention to
in other words if you're trying to
convince yourself that you'll never be
held accountable you can rationalize
this by rejecting belief in God
we could say that about atheism
but that's just not what these Psalms
are about
these Psalms are making a point about
human beings whose sin
and that's all of us
not just atheists
[Music]